my dad although he's terrible on the
phone so that would be the time that
you'd actually push me to call him and
then I'd get nothing I don't have a lot
of celebrity friends sadly or not so
sadly I love my friends which makes
answering this question very
boring well I had done comedy for such a
long time but I had this desire to kind
of explore something a little bit deeper
and a little bit more serious
considering it's a movie about grief
it's also about friendship and it's also
about coming to terms with yourself and
and self-improvement oh oh
no it's the underside of the I don't
know what you call it but the gentle
little soft un